plongée dans l'obscurité muni d'une
lampe torche les visiteurs de
l'événement vision nocturne proposée au
musée départemental maurice denis ont pu
découvrir les oeuvres sous un autre
aspect c'est vraiment l'idée de
bousculer un peu notre musée à la
réouverture en proposant de voir notre
musée autrement et c'est aussi une
manière de combattre cette idée des
musées comme lieu passéiste au contraire
on veut affirmer les musées comme des
lieux de vie comme des lieux de passage
et des lieux également ouvert à l'art
contemporain
c'est la première fois que le musée
maurice denis participent à la nuit
blanche evènement franciliens dédié à la
création contemporaine durant une nuit
au programme ce soir là autre que la
déambulation nocturne une compagnie de
danse est intervenu au milieu des
oeuvres ce soir en fait un petit
animations du musée pendant la nuit
avec des extraits de pièces en fait
c'était court extrait de pièce de notre
répertoire qu'on a essayé de faire
résonner avec des oeuvres du musée la
compagnie de poésie demain on déménage
également présente à créer un corpus de
poèmes autour du thème vision nocturne
et en correspondance avec les oeuvres du
musée et intervenir en plus dans un
cadre comme celui là avec des avec des
peintures c'est vraiment ça apporte
encore à la magie de
de la chose qu'on attend de la soirée ce
que ce soit un beau moment de partage
autour de la peinture et de la poésie
l'exposition maurice denis bonheur rêver
est également à découvrir en journée
jusqu'au 29 mai prochain